why did it take so long exactly I have
the first Apple TV set-top box and I
haven't felt the urge to get a new one
because there haven't been that many
updates to it over the years this would
be the most significant update since the
beginning as you mentioned slimmer
faster there's also supposed to be an
app store a developer kit that would
enable developers to develop apps for
this TV set-top box now we don't know if
or why this this is really indeed coming
out in September this has been reported
by BuzzFeed that Apple has been working
on the set-top box that they were
planning to introduce it in June that
they pushed it now to sep tember but
what's very unclear is why they would be
doing it in September this is a time
that's normally reserved to unveil the
new phones it's also unclear if this
would come out in partnership with an
Apple TV streaming service which we've
reported that Apple is working on that
we know they've run into some challenges
in terms of striking deals with content
providers that now according to BuzzFeed
isn't happening until next year but to
be clear we don't know if it's happening
at all hmmm and what's interesting
though is why it's been so hard to
release it right I mean you mentioned
that you haven't had an update I I own
Apple TV I don't had cut the cord
completely is it because i diverted so
much attention to the the watch or what
is it you know there were reports that
apple was working on a TV set and that
that TV set has been shelved it doesn't
seem that the TV streaming service has
been shelled as of yet but what we've
heard and what sources have been telling
us is that it's been very difficult to
secure partnerships with content
providers on recode spoke with CBS and
les Moonves indicated that he had been
talking to Apple but that the main
sticking point was money though he's
excited to work with them but we don't
really know what kind of real progress
has been made it is it is a difficult
business and the content providers are
on lockdown essentially and we know that
Apple doesn't want to do it if they're
not gonna crush everybody else when they
do they want it to be good